what's up kicks family meech here back
with our debate show
sneaker swap where we argue a lot
i have the usual suspects with me cj
teledano
christian pierre jeff johnson fellas
what's going on today
what's up what's up the deal is
i got a new topic for y'all okay if you
had the yeezy quantum
would you trade it for the puma rs
dreamer anybody ready to go up first
i'll go um i wouldn't trade them because
i know i could find a hypebeast to give
me
all the money in the world to get them
quantums that's the only reason why if
we're talking about keeping for my
self yeah i'm trading them i like the j
cole pumas i like the colorway better i
like the design better
i feel like i could wear it as a
lifestyle shoe and the yeezy quantums
they just
they don't appeal to me at all only from
a financial perspective where i could
make a lot of money
selling it to a yeezy or a kanye fan
y'all can have them i don't need them
damn
damn i feel the opposite though i mean i
feel like i would keep the easy
basketballs because they are going to
turn more heads than the the dreamers i
just feel like the dreamers look like
every other basketball shoe
you know and also too the narrative of
like j cole playing in the league like
all we've seen is him just you know
doing some warm-up drills so
i mean i don't want to hate on him
before you know he actually does a try
out
but i just think that you know yeezy has
more credibility in the sneaker line and
the sneaker uh
industry so i think i'm gonna go i'm
gonna keep my yeezy basketballs
and like we saw we saw ingram playing
the all-star game with them so they
worked there
yeah jeff i'm i'm i'm against you also
man i'm uh
i don't know bro i'm keeping i'm keeping
these bro i'm keeping these quantums
made
wait what was that do that again yeah
yeah i'm keeping these real quick
oh man i'm keeping these um i don't know
man i guess
i guess for what it's worth it's the
difference between like what do you like
whatever your like preferences is
performance
is it is it like the style and
aesthetics and i'm surprised you of all
people jeff like i'm use your word like
these quantums have like an avant-garde
style to them you know what i mean
so now but like i said i really do
appreciate this shoe like i'm not really
a fan of high-top speakers like that
but and like it's kind of comparable to
like i guess some of his other shoes
maybe even the 750 in length beach you
wouldn't know because you have those
like what that style was like but i kind
of like you know little
little kind of like i guess prime knit
style over here with the z like a zebra
print kind of moving over to the side
i really do like the suede on the toe
like that's kind of like a nice little
touch
and the only issue i really had with
these shoes was that like
they were there there's no half sizes
i'm like 11 and a half 12. like so i had
to get a full 12. so it's like a little
tight but honestly
these look kind of like when i first
jeff i didn't think they were big too
but when i had them off feet that's when
i realized now these were perfect did
avant-garde mean uh
ugly and french the name changed oh
these things are yo
i mean man like i thought i thought you
were picking up
like a a brick to throw at the screen
when you
when i saw them straight up like i i
think they're whack
i think they're well i'll say it
straight up like i'm not sure koda i
think they're whack i think
i'll give you an a for it for innovation
and trying something new but everything
that's
new ain't cool yeah but i mean like what
cj said like before man like this
and i it hurts because i'm a huge cool
fan i had to take my dreamville shirt
off just to put this [ __ ] on
i didn't feel like i was crazy like it
the puma rs dreamer reminds me of a lot
of the hoop shoes man like
i i'm i'm good on that like i could get
way i get those shoes from nike adidas
from everybody else i don't need a puma
uh basketball tree right now that looks
like that so so you would wear them just
because they're
different not because they look good so
i one
i actually the style of it and two i
appreciate more of the innovation
towards it opposed to the rs dreamer
and like maybe because i'm not like a
super hooper anymore i
i kind of like lean towards this more
than the dreamer to begin with
christian retired from the game and all
of a sudden he don't associate with
hoop kicks i mean i see you i see you i
christian i think you hit on a great
point with innovation we always come
back to innovation
uh on sneaker swap i think that's some
that's one of the most important things
to us at
all times innovation innovation
innovation the quantums do
uh a really great job i haven't seen
anything like that on the basketball
court before and of course i can rock
them
um off the court what jeff you seen
something like that on the basketball
court am i crazy never heard of you ever
heard of the shaq gnosis
the shatnoses though that the shagnoses
don't compete with the with the
shotguns yeah the diagnosis looked like
something
it looked like you know a hypnotic swirl
don't look like anything it looks like
if somebody tried to get permed waves
that's exactly what it looks
like when people perm their waves and
cheat that's like hgh in sports for
those who don't know
those look like permed waves
at least it's inspired what are the
dreamers inspired by
it's beside my game going platinum with
no features
that's what it's inspired by bro
i mean but that's what kills me with
this whole thing right like we've seen
kanye do what oh
five six different types of yeezys and
then the quantum comes out
and i was really excited for them
initially but it's like i didn't
like i heard about them one time ingram
warm in the all-star game and then i
haven't heard about them since
you know like there hasn't been any
pivotal moments in the shoe for me to
like really really care about it outside
of it being super innovative
versus the dreamer you know i see kuzma
hitting game winners and um
ayton's hooping and um danny green's
hooping and like you know
all the all eyes are on the bubble right
now you know like where is yeezy during
this time they have all these
in the bubble but they're not making any
impact is he being selected i mean we
can obviously see how connie would be
more selective with who's wearing his
shoes so
i mean i i i don't know whose choice
that is that not many people are wearing
easy basketballs out there if it's not
james harden it's not uh damien lillard
who else is is going to be wearing
uh adidas basketball shirt well it would
have to be one of their like
or athlete guys so i think that's why so
for one i will say
um i think easy and adidas owned
all-star weekend fully
i think the with the release of the
quantums and like the hype like
connie legit brought tanks to chicago
like legit brought tanks out there
and had people running after his troops
and massively it's going going crazy
before he had cueva out there giving his
shoes out like
it was a crazy scene and just to think
like people legit gave up
people legit gave up their um their
nikes like
their fear of god once don't give a
legit yellow fear god want to trade for
it
so if you don't think that hype is there
and people wanted that shoe
it's like it's the proof is already
there to be honest i'll say
the hype was there but i feel like some
of that was manufactured because
i do not believe anyone on planet from
this timeline
is giving up the fear of gods for those
maybe
maybe the yeezy nikes i give up fear of
gods for those the first the first
easies i give up the fear of gods for
those
and and also not for nothing it's a
little tone deaf to bring tanks
into chicago just just me just are we
are we are we kanye west for being tone
deaf
i mean that's no surprise there has to
be a tone there first
right oh wow you're not wrong i will say
that
i'm i'm i'm just saying like you know
and then
not for nothing that all happened and as
somebody
as somebody we we was in i'll say that
was not warm it's very cold out here
there we go he would have been those
tanks were warm
i hope those tanks were warm because it
was bleeding when we was out there
but remember also that weekend
just had the the kobe solemn
um feel to it so anything else that
happened outside of it the fact that
it got attention i give kanye that
because
it was all about honoring kobe and the
legacy
and just everything it was not even from
from his tragic passing and all the
um and gigi and everyone who lost their
life
so that that also kind of took away like
if it was a normal all-star weekend
he would he would have had it vibrating
like he probably would have had the
tanks like in front of the arena type
yeah but with kanye in chicago though he
he feels like he can do whatever he
wants
i don't know if i can disagree with him
you know that that's actually ground
that's true if anyone could bring tanks
to chicago and nobody bats an
eyelash it he's one of the home right um
the dreamer is honestly in the lead it's
a better shoe right now it's not crazy
that
puma gave their artist their rapper
a signature shoe before any of their i
go who's in the shoe before any of these
guys like who's
yeah kuzma wearing them you have danny
green wearing them i mean like maybe
they're not selling numbers like them
but they're actually hoopers
i think if you're looking at the names
on puma's roster
and who is the most established who has
the best resume and we talk about a
signature shoe
a signature shoe is earned not given the
only person that's earned anything on
that roster is j cole
period and have you earned the court
though bro but then why is he getting a
basketball sneaker
because now you get to tie the story
line into him making the league
don't get me wrong like it's it's
definitely part of the marketing scheme
but if they like if there's anyone that
deserves to show us jay cloak man
why do we wear basketball sneakers to go
for lifestyle
you know what i'm saying who else has
some really dope who shoes or who who
are your favorite uh
rappers with hoop shoes i'm a i'm gonna
put it on its head and i'm gonna say
my favorite rapper sneaker collab is
kobe that's my favorite route
it counts tell me
but i like i like dame's line but i i
like questions yeah
i like the questions way better so if
it's not if it's either it's a tie
between kobe or
a uh actually you know what no no my bad
let me reel it back twist them
no platinum recording artist shaquille
o'neal
let me boil that let me let me put some
respect because yo
he when he came out with his his first
sneaker with the reebok pump
those were fire then he came back like
when they started carving out his own
line
his run is kind of long like dmx it was
it was short
but it was prolific as hell kanye is has
done a really good job
of uh cementing himself as like a
household name
but travis every sneaker that he touches
whether that be uh the the air jordan
ones that he flipped
you know he touched sb's and the stock
market rose so i think once travis
really starts dipping into that
basketball bag and we've already seen
some videos
of travis hooping you know he has the
james harding connection
um travis could really be the one to to
to set the tone for this is how it's
supposed to be done by rappers in the
secret game i think j cole got off on
the right foot but
you know it's travis's game to win i
honestly think pharrell has the best
basketball
um sneakers i like i like his new his
crazy bluesy wear two that he has like
the kind of multicolored one and i also
like
the original like white it's like a
white high top one without an
ankle like ankle sock around on the um
or soccer on the ankle basically
that was pretty fire and then like he
also did they never released but they
were pretty fire the mvp colorway he did
for
james harden i think all those were
different and unique in their own right
and i thought those were like honestly
one of the best ones like i think
i know you have others like pusha t and
dave have their collab those are cool
um like you mentioned travis in the 33s
but i i think
ferrarelle has the best one that's like
legit
so far and where do you think drake
falls into that category as well
um drake's are interesting because like
he has
i don't know do you guys see pj tucker
wear those like 16s yeah
those are sick yeah those are fire and i
i normally don't like 16 at all so like
that
i just need drake to release these
because like drake has a lot of just
hidden samples that you'll just see
randomly like whatever the snakeskin
elevens whatever they are and like
those actually drop those are fire you
know what i mean to me though
the all the drake stuff just feels like
colorways they just feel like
exclusive color was you know yeah like
again i i love when
when these rappers or artists take you
know interpretations and flip the swoosh
around or use a different material but
and i think drake has that ability and
maybe he'll take more chances like
travis has almost like
pushed it or like you know open the door
so so drake could do that
uh and i hope drake takes that liberty
at some point here
real quick just because we're talking
about puma and like dreamer and i think
someone mentioned it before
uh lamello there's like rumors he's
signing with puma
is is little like could you see lamelo
get his shoe
like before all the other guys that
signed with puma i guess like after cole
oh man you know so i was thinking about
this and it it kind of hurts me because
like i like to think i'm a player's
first person right
and with players first like you're
always thinking all right respect you
know you gotta
show respect for your elders these guys
the cultural impact that's impact on
basketball court yes but like outside of
just a back support court like
you don't really hear from this hear
from these guys lamelo is the kind of
person that
he cannot walk through the mall without
security you know
if he gets a shoe before these guys i'm
not gonna be mad at him because that
[ __ ] is moving off the shelf
we've already seen it bbb already did
their thing we know the potential of
what lamo's brand can be
like if a melo lamello's if lamelo signs
with pooping he already has a signature
shoe in the bag for him
melo is the first influencer
that could go on the lottery you know
what i mean like you run his numbers
those are like boy band numbers you know
his here's a stat for you cj
okay okay lamela ball has 5.5 million
followers on instagram
it's crazy well it says 5 million 5.5
million followers on instagram
cold world i can say cole right yeah
it's a no-brainer
and lamelo plays basketball in the nba
and we'll have a basketball shoe pay him
puma
jeff is roasting them but give us a real
review ah i got you right now these are
the quads right here jeff
i got you these these shoes that you saw
i'm throwing like a block shape action
wow they're not heavy
not really they not really they're not
heavy i wouldn't like i said it might be
a little heavy if you're gonna try to
ball in them but it might have like
a foam positive heavy feel to it but if
you're just like casually
if you're just casually wearing it like
it's chill new york sales just shot up
yeah bro i i just got i just got
fatigued my calves just started
throbbing